what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we just watched moon
night episode two right away before we
get started let me know what you thought
about this episode in the comments below
did you think it was better did you like
it more or not so much as the first
episode rate it 1 out of 10 down below
now i'm a little sick and my voice is a
little rough right now so i apologize
but let's just dive right into this
breakdown and talk about the things that
you need to know about episode 2 because
there's a lot of things that actually
connect to the comics in this episode
including who mark spector actually is
so we'll dive into a little bit of his
backstory who layla is and what exactly
is arthur trying to do does he truly
want to summon ahmed to release her so
she can judge people or does he perhaps
have an agenda of his own i think he has
a different agenda than he's stating so
let's dive into this week's moon night
episode breakdown and of course if
you're new and you love marvel be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos now i actually
love this opening scene because it plays
off of some things that are talked about
in the comics at the end of last episode
arthur had hunted steven down in the
museum and at night when stephen was
getting off work steven thought he was
trying to get a stray dog out of the
museum but then arthur gets on the
intercom and tells him to give him the
scare an egyptian jackal is then
summoned and goes after stephen in which
he runs and hides into the bathroom
shuts the door and the jackal is trying
to break through and this is where mark
comes out in the reflection and says
give me control i will save us steven
struggles with reality saying that it's
not real it's not real mark says it is
give me control stephen finally concedes
moon knight comes out for the first time
and he beats the crap out of the jackal
and this picks up immediately after that
with steven in bed and we can hear the
sounds of moon knight beating up the
jackal stephen then wakes up and he
starts running in which the restraint
catches him he falls on the floor and he
starts to go okay maybe it was just a
dream also if you noticed there were no
feet prints in the sand so mark's mind
would have automatically thought okay i
didn't get up last night this must have
been a dream because there are no feet
prints in the sand but this is where
mark kind of starts to begin to break
mentally which is you know totally
understandable but he goes to the mirror
looks at himself and says are you there
talking to mark trying to see if it
comes out in which of course nothing
happens and he says i didn't think so so
here we really see steven start to
struggle with what is real and what is
in his mind and what his dreams at night
now it seems like steven is kind of
leaning towards the side that these are
just dreams and in his head but notice
as he walks up the stairs to go into the
museum he turns back and he looks to see
if anybody might be following him any of
arthur's men but notice this when he
walks into the museum he is genuinely
surprised to see maintenance in there he
takes a look at the repair man's toolbox
and then he looks into the museum and he
gives this look that is kind of like was
it real did that really happen and he
sees that there's damage done and a
section is crossed off and he's even
actually surprised he goes up to jb and
he says it's proper mad isn't it and he
even asks what happened bruv says it
looks like it was burst pipes but it
doesn't look like that to me and that's
where steven realizes oh my gosh last
night was real so steven says i should
check the security footage with you
because i might have some information
obviously steven expects to see the
egyptian jackal and moon knight both on
the security cameras and he even tells
jb hey what you're about to see is like
area 51 mi6 bonker stuff you're about to
see but i actually love this part
because nothing shows up on the camera
we cannot see the egyptian jackal but
steven swears there was something
chasing him he says there was a big
hound chasing him and jb says oh yeah
hound of the baskervilles was it now
this is just a tiny little easter egg
hound of the baskervilles was one of the
most famous stories ever written and
it's actually a sherlock holm story
sherlock holmes and of course dr watson
are investigating murders that were
caused by a huge hound it doesn't really
have any relevance to the story but they
threw it in there for a little easter
egg now i really love this part because
now steven is actually thinking he might
be going crazy he tells jb to fast
forward to the end and we see him
walking out he is not in the moon night
clothes but we see mark not stephen but
mark looking into the camera jb says
it's still you but steven looks at him
and realizes that's not him and he says
that's not me so from here the pressure
on steven's mind is really getting to
him he really cannot tell what is real
and what's not and it really doesn't
help that the next scene that we get is
of him meeting with somebody at the
museum who says that he's talked to a
bunch of his colleagues and says that
it's clear that he's been struggling
lately and basically says that he's kind
of losing it and he's recommending a
group of doctors to him and this is
where steven realizes oh okay they think
i'm crazy but it's funny that steven
actually looks like he knows he might
actually be crazy the hr man says you're
not alone and stephen says yeah that's
part of the problem the hr guy asks him
if he has any company property on him in
which mark pulls out a key which we find
out is to the storage locker and the
phone then we have a heartbreaking scene
where he has to give up his name tag he
truly loved working at the museum he
wanted to be a tour guide but
unfortunately it didn't work out for him
and you just really root for steven but
unfortunately he's not having much luck
right now but then we go to stephen
talking to his friend the golden man and
here he's really trying to justify these
things that have been happening to him
trying to say i'm not crazy i swear i
found these hidden things in my flat so
he decides that he's going to
investigate them and it's interesting
that he says he's going to do it to
prove to himself that he's not mad so he
finds out that the key is to central
london storage and he checked a bunch of
them before finally arriving at the one
where he has his storage or where mark
has the storage and the guy actually
recognizes him and says i know you
you're storage number 43. now this could
be referring to moon knight vol 1 number
43. dubbed multiple maniacs where he
faces off against some doppelgangers of
some heroes like daredevil not really
pertinent to the story but multiple
maniacs could be referring to the state
of mind of stephen grant right now he
has inside of him konchu and mark
spector now he takes him to the storage
and this is where he finds all of mark
spector's stuff the mercenary he sees
all of his stuff his spare change of
clothes and he finds a duffel bag and he
goes up and he opens it and what does he
find a gun money in a bunch of different
currencies and a passport that says mark
specter on it this is where he learns
the full name of mark he learns his last
name a specter and he a big sigh
basically saying to himself
it's real mark is real there's
essentially somebody else living inside
of me and he also finds the scarab in
there which basically solidifies that
everything that's been happening to him
is indeed real now steven realizes that
this looks like a compass except it's
not pointing north and it's later on
revealed by arthur that it is indeed a
compass but it's pointing not north but
to amit's grave now here's where mark
shows up and actually reveals everything
to stephen and this is where he reveals
that he is the avatar of konchu he
serves him as his fist of justice and he
makes it sound like his task is almost
done this plays a major part into the
story later on but something to notice
is that mark says we deliver conscious
justice to those who are hurt this is a
really big part that we're about to get
to in a later scene now from here steven
kind of doesn't buy the whole konju god
of the moon thing he says it's the
stupidest thing he's ever heard and he
starts to have a panic attack and here
we find that mark can only communicate
with steven through reflections we see
this when he is communicating with him
through the reflection of the gun mark
says he made a deal with konchu and the
deal's almost done he's about to finish
it and he'll never hear from him again
but he needs to let him finish it and
give him the body but this is where
stephen kind of goes okay i'm crazy so
i'm gonna turn myself in and hopefully
some therapists are going to give me
some pills that make everything go away
and make me all right however as he
tries to run he runs into konchu and we
have a really cool scene here that is
very much like a horror film scene
something that we've really never seen
before from marvel and it's a really
nice change now eventually he runs in
the concho and kanchu says give it back
you full now what's interesting to note
here is that konchu can't actually
physically keep him from going anywhere
and this is pointed out in a later scene
where konchu makes the wind blow really
really hard and arthur says don't worry
that's all he can do because remember he
is the avatar for kanchu kanshu isn't
actually physically there in that realm
on earth and we find out a little bit
more about this in a later scene but
steven runs out absolutely petrified and
eventually he runs into the street where
we meet layla now she of course thinks
it's mark and she says is steven the
latest in your fake identities that
you've come up with clearly mark as a
mercenary has used fake identities
before stephen gets on the back of her
moped and we find out that layla is
actually his wife now of course it's
mark's wife and not stephen's wife and
this is important to note because again
like i've said mark is the main person
mark is the original host of the body
steven is a personality that has been
made up and kind of taken on a mind of
its own so the real life of this body
belongs to mark now as layla expresses
her concerns for mark over the past
couple of months she does mention that
she knows he has the suit and thought
that he would be okay because he has the
suit clearly showing that they have in
fact been through a lot together now of
course steven is confused and he keeps
asking her questions like did you say
you're my wife are we married but laila
thinks that it's just an act that he's
putting on because people are following
them layla gets tired of it but steven
says hey if you take me back to my flat
i'll tell you everything so we get to
the apartment and we notice that layla
has never been there before she walks in
she's very curious about everything she
walks right up to the fish tank to look
at the fish and it looks like steven
walks up on the other side but then we
quickly realized that this is actually
mark in the reflection of the fish tank
and he says that she shouldn't be there
now steven says out loud i just want my
life back because he's talking to mark
layla obviously responds in which
stephen says oh i wasn't talking to you
i was talking to myself sort of now this
can contribute to layla thinking that
steven or mark is actually mentally
unstable because this kind of happens in
the comics where they don't actually
know if kanchu is real or not now layla
is still steven's wife and she thinks
that he might be living with somebody
else in which he replies oh no this is
my mom's flat now we've heard about
steven's mom a lot but we don't actually
know who she is yet but layla says oh so
you two are talking again which really
confuses steven but this makes you
wonder who exactly is steven's mom
because again mark is the actual
rightful holder of the body so it would
actually be mark's mom so who exactly is
stephen talking to when he calls his mom
is he talking to mark's mother and she
realizes that hey my son might be a
little crazy here so i'll talk to steven
this other personality but i won't
actually talk to mark i'm sure we'll
find that out in a later episode but if
you have any guesses let me know in the
comments now layla starts going through
some of mark's stuff we can see some
book titles one is the man and the ice
now this is an actual book that talks
about the discovery of a 5 000 year old
body reveals the secret of the stone age
but when i think of the man in the ice
in the mcu i think of steve rogers but i
doubt it's about captain america below
that we see a book titled the
intervention which kind of just happened
to stephen with the person at the museum
telling him that hey we're going to give
you some doctors to get you some help
then layla picks up a book by marceline
debar van moe and this is interesting
because we kind of see the split of
mark's personality here layla explains
that that's her favorite poet and it's
stevens as well now mark would obviously
know this and it seems like the part
that did know this split off into
stephen and he subconsciously knew that
poet and it became his favorite poet so
we do kind of see parts of mark breaking
off into steven's personality we see the
same thing happen when layla says so
you're learning hieroglyphics as well
again steven could have subconsciously
went to learn hieroglyphics because mark
knew that layla liked hieroglyphics now
layla doesn't really buy any of this and
she thinks it's just mark messing with
her and she pulls out divorce papers and
says this is what you wanted however
steven won't sign them because as we can
tell here he's kind of into her which
obviously makes sense because mark
married her so he's gonna like her a
little bit at least but at this point
steven has kind of accepted what is
happening to him and he starts to tell
leila everything because he thinks that
she's the only person that might be able
to help him and he's about to show her
the scarab but mark mentions from the
reflection that if he shows her what's
in the bag and tells her everything he's
gonna get her killed and this
automatically makes steven stop however
leila budges her way in and finds a
scarab she's obviously pissed but steven
explains it's not me i'm not mark take
the scarab now layla actually tells us
what this is she says it's the scarab
pointed to ahmed's ushabti now in
ancient egypt anushapti was placed in
the tomb among the grave of the gods so
essentially the scarab points to the
grave or tomb of amit and we know why
they were looking for the scarab ahmet
has been judging people before death via
arthur and they want to resurrect her
now layla does say you don't know why
we've been looking for this and we don't
know that full story yet but we do know
that arthur does want to resurrect amit
now shortly after two cops come to the
door and if you're watching this you've
already seen the episode or don't care
about spoilers and we know that these
two cops aren't actually cops they're
working for arthur so they make it seem
like they're cops they intimidate and
they scare steven they put him in
handcuffs and take him away and in this
car ride we learn the actual origin
story of mark spector from the comics
and the female cop kind of partly
explains how mark spector became moon
knight she runs a report and says that
mark spectre was part of a team of
mercenaries that hit a dick site in
egypt and on the screen you can see a
bunch of dead bodies covered up then she
says here's what they did to the
archaeologists they zip tied them up and
shot them in the back of the head
execution style now of course steven
says no that wasn't me because it was
actually mark however it wasn't actually
mark now they arrive at the location
which is not a police station which
confuses mark and he says i thought we
were going to the police station but
then the man adjusts the mirror and we
see the scale of ahmet on his arm and he
says why would you think that now from
here steven asks for help from a lady
outside but he quickly realizes that she
also has the scale on her arm and that
he's pretty much in a city of the cult
that follows arthur and ahmet but what's
interesting here is that you can
actually physically see mark try to take
over steven's body steven all of a
sudden looks like he's in pain it looks
like he's struggling and then we see a
reflection of mark and it does look like
he's trying to take over the body
however steven is resilient and he
manages to keep control now from here
steven says i saw what you did to those
people i'm never giving you control
again but mark says it's not what you
think and this is where the comic origin
comes in moon knight's origin is
basically what has been said already
mark spector was a mercenary and he went
on a job in egypt now from here he went
to an archaeologist's dig site with
another mercenary called bushman at the
dig site buschmann would end up killing
the archaeologists specifically dr
allrun and he kills the archaeologist
right in front of his daughter marlene
who i actually believe they switched to
layla for the moon night series but
after buschmann ruthlessly killed the
archaeologist mark actually stood up to
him and tried to fight him however he
lost and he was beaten pretty much to
death in fact he does die but before he
dies he's taken in front of a statue of
konshu there he dies but is quickly
resurrected he's resurrected by kanchu
and he's perfectly healed but it came
with a price he now has to be konshu's
fist of justice and this is what mark
was talking to stephen about inside of
the storage locker he's the avatar of
konchu he's his fist of justice he
judges who hurt innocent people now in
the comics mark gets up but before he
leaves he takes robes off of the statue
of kanchu which go on to become the moon
night suit and he goes back with marlene
who goes on to become the love of his
life which is why i believe layla is
simply marlene from the comics and he
goes back with his best friend frenchie
as well who we have seen mentioned in
the series in the first episode when
stephen found mark's phone and went
through the missed calls there was a
missed call from somebody called doo
champ and duchamp is short for jean-paul
frenchy duchamp who is basically his
number one man pretty much alfred to
batman frenchy to moon knight and keep
in mind the ribs because we're gonna
come back to that in just a bit now
instead of the character bushman i'm
pretty sure they just replaced him with
arthur here arthur was never really a
big moon knight character so they're
basically doing what they want with the
story here but the big question is did
arthur kill layla's father we don't find
out this episode but i'm sure more
details are gonna come about this later
on now while steven was in the car
arthur really ended up tricking him he
turned on the microphone so he could
hear what he's saying and he now
realizes that steven does indeed have
more than one person in him he even goes
on to say no wonder your scales don't
balance from the first episode when he
actually judged him the scales didn't
balance and he said you have chaos in
you but he says your scales don't
balance because he has a lot of
different people inside of him and he
even says do you think kanchu chose you
because your mind would be so easy to
break or because it was broken already
and in the comics this is actually one
of the reasons that konju did choose
mark spector but stephen says i'm not
broken now koncho appears and he says
steven kill him and what's really
interesting is that arthur actually
realizes that kancha was there and he
seems to know what he's saying but then
the wind blows super hard and arthur
says that's all he can do without your
help so again referring to what i said
before konchu actually can't hurt
anybody physically that's why he has an
avatar because konchu isn't actually
physically in our realm now arthur now
realizing that steven and mark are
indeed two separate people he tries to
kind of reason with stephen he takes him
inside and we actually hear the same
music that we heard in the very
beginning of the opening scene of the
first episode of moon knight that was of
arthur crushing up the glass and putting
it inside of the slippers as they go in
we can actually tell that they are
indeed in the same place so this is sort
of arthur's base camp here now from here
we sort of have a battle of the gods
which is pretty interesting here arthur
explains that ahmed judges people before
they can actually commit bad things
before they actually do evil but kanji
explains that konchu himself is real
justice because he only punishes people
who have actually done bad things so
this is sort of the battle of the gods
the battle of different beliefs the
opinion that konchu judges people too
late and ahmet is casting judgment now
in advance and this is why they plan to
resurrect her so she can judge the
entire earth and that's why they need
the scarab so they can find almonds too
we also find out that arthur was a
avatar for konchu before and clearly the
two of them didn't really agree with
each other since now he is the avatar
for ahmed and you have to wonder did
arthur make a deal with amit to stop
becoming conscious avatar because mark
seems to be pretty locked in in being
the avatar of konchu it seems like
something he can't get out of so you
have to wonder how did arthur get out of
being conscious avatar i think that he
might have made a deal with ahmed but i
also think that his motives aren't
exactly what they seem but here we find
out that there are some flaws in ahmed's
plans steven starts asking questions
like well what about babies would you
kill a baby if
50 60 70 years from now he's going to do
something bad and arthur replies
basically yes and this is where you see
how delusional the cult is they actually
make rational justifications for doing
horrible things like killing children
but arthur says sometimes the cure is a
little taste of the disease the
difference between medicine and poison
sometimes is only dosage but this is
where steven kind of draws the line he's
like i'm not telling you anything about
the scarab because you're gonna kill
some babies and this is where arthur
kind of has drawn his line as well and
here is where we are introduced to
ahmet's kane or staff arthur explains
that it's ahmed's gift to her first
avatar now we don't know if arthur is
her first avatar and she gave it to him
or if she had other avatars before and
he simply inherited the staff for kane
when he eventually became her avatar but
he does explain that it contains a tiny
sliver of her power and notice how it
kind of glows purple we'll get to this
in just a bit but layla shows up with
the scarab and this actually kind of
pisses conch you off and he states
there's no deal in this mark you better
fix this and kanchu has promised mark
that this is going to be his last
mission as kanchu's avatar then he'll be
set free now again very inconveniently
laila does not believe mark she thinks
mark is messing with her and that steven
does not exist so she tells him summon
the suit she shows up with a very cocky
attitude because she believes that mark
could simply summon the moon knight suit
and everything will be okay now steven
is incredibly confused so layla just
simply says alright fine keep the scarab
safe and the two of them run and arthur
has had enough and we see the staff's
power now this really really reminds me
of the power stone it glows purple like
the power stone and even when he puts
the staff on the ground it really looks
like essan the searcher and guardians of
the galaxy putting the staff that held
the power stone on the planet which
eventually caused the planet to explode
now i don't think this is the power
stone or its drawing power from the
power stone because of course the
infinity stones from our universe were
destroyed but it sure does seem like
cosmic power so perhaps the source of
the power might have come from the same
place after all a cosmic egyptian god
created the staff so the staff although
it does have some magic to it as arthur
summons an egyptian jackal it may have
massive power like the infinity stone it
clearly has magic from another realm as
the jackal is summoned and laila can't
see it just like the footage from the
cameras at the museum didn't show the
jackal either and this is really kind of
interesting here because again you go
back to the is steven actually crazy is
this actually real nobody can see it but
him now layla and steven managed to
escape to a room and they shut the door
and clearly you can tell that something
is trying to break down the door and
steven kind of gets overwhelmed here
mark is yelling at him through
reflections saying let me in give me the
body leila sitting there telling him
your name is mark you can do this you
need to fight and stephen kind of just
shuts down but then layla actually
switches from calling him mark to
calling him stephen saying steven you
can do this but again it's all kind of
too much and he says i'm sorry i can't
then the egyptian jackal busts through
the door which stephen can see but layla
can't again we wonder if it's actually
real but then it tackles steven outside
of the window and he's falling down
about to hit the ground where we hear
konchu yell summon the suit in which
steven just kind of yells suit because
he doesn't know how it works now
eventually when he hits the ground we do
see that he has indeed summoned the moon
knight suit however it is very different
than the typical moon knight suit it is
actually the mr knight suit now steven
summoned the suit like this because when
he hears suit this is what he is
thinking of in his mind a dress suit
mark says what the hell are you wearing
you're supposed to summon the ceremonial
armor from konchu's temple this is the
robes or armor that he takes in the
comics from the tomb before he leaves
right after he was brought back to life
by konchu now mark asked him if he still
has the scarab in which when he's
looking for the scarab he pulls out two
poles and these are what i believe to be
his trunchion which is from the comics
his trenchion has multiple purposes in
the comics and it's basically a
multi-purpose weapon it can be used as a
bow staff a grappling hook a baton and a
cane so very very useful now as he pulls
these out he gets attacked by the jackal
and the jackal basically starts throwing
him around and here's the very very
important part we can see here that
steven isn't actually crazy we can see
that layla can see something is fighting
him and sees him getting picked up by
something invisible and then she herself
actually gets hit by the jackal why
can't she see it though no one can
likely see it unless they've been given
some sort of gift by the gods arthur was
giving this sort of gift from amit and
steven through mark has it from konchu
now after steven gets roughed up a
little bit by the jackal and so does
leila stephen actually gets some courage
mark says give me control steve and you
can't handle this and which stephen
replies i think i can and he gets a
little bit of confidence and he starts
hyping himself starts talking to the
jackal he says float like a butterfly
sting like a bee which is what muhammad
ali said the world heavyweight boxing
champion and steven has the confidence
and the jackal even jumps at him and
steven stands his ground and manages to
punch the jackal in the face with a huge
blow now unfortunately steven gets a
little cocky here and the jackal
continues to rough him up however an
incoming car is coming and steven
manages to throw the jackal into the car
right before it hits them and you can
see that the car is super messed up from
hitting the jackal further confirming
the jackal is real but people just can't
see it now from here mark talks to
steven again of course through a
reflection and he actually gives him a
little bit of praise he tells him that
was a hell of a punch but mark tells
stephen that he needs to look around
people could get hurt if he doesn't give
him the body and good old stephen
doesn't want to risk anyone getting hurt
so he gives control to mark and now we
see the true moon knight come out in the
ceremonial armor and we see him take his
crescents off of his chest which in the
comics are actually made out of
adamantium which in the comics is also
what wolverine's claws are made out of
and if you notice here moon knight can't
fly or jump really high and he pretty
much can't do anything that's super we
see him climb up the wall not jump up it
or fly but climb like a normal human he
kind of just gets super strength and the
suit provides them with increased
durability and it heals him but besides
that he doesn't have a lot of massive
powers but we see him lead the jackal
away jumping from the rooftops we see
the classic moon knight jump in front of
the crescent moon and his powers once
upon a time in the comics did depend on
the moon cycle but they ended up
changing that so who knows if that'll be
the case in the mcu now mark spectre's
moon knight defeats the jackal in a
pretty epic way impaling it then
catching his crescent in an epic way
after but unfortunately he loses the
scarab now a random citizen finds a
scarab in which arthur goes up to him
and says i'm sorry that belongs to me i
can offer you food and clothing but i'm
afraid i can't offer you this now here's
something really interesting that
happens we see arthur take the hand of
this citizen and he kills him but it
doesn't look like he used the scales to
judge him which is kind of fishy does
arthur want to release ahmed for another
reason that he's preaching because it
really doesn't seem like he judged this
person for amit right here it seems like
he just kind of murdered him perhaps he
wants ahmed's powers for himself and has
figured out a way to take them after he
resurrects her now we go back to mark
who is out of the moonlight armor now
and we see that steven is now on the
outside and from here we find out some
pretty crucial information steven says
that he can barely move in the
reflections and he tries to take the
body back from mark after mark refuses
to give it to him and is very
unsuccessful even though he tries very
hard mark explains that they've always
managed to keep a wall between them but
something's changed the one who is in
control of the body at the time has
become stronger and most of the time it
will take all of the person's will power
to be a fly in the wall so as we can see
here it's actually very hard for the
person who doesn't have control over the
body to actually be in the picture and
here steven realizes that the reason his
life is so screwed up the reason that he
can't get a date he can't keep a job he
can't keep a goldfish alive is because
mark has been taking over his body now
from here mark goes on to kind of say we
wouldn't be alive if it wasn't for
konchu which again goes back to the
comics where konchu brought mark back to
life after he died and mark explains
that he has to repay a debt to conscious
after he repays that he's done he'll be
gone forever stephen will never see mark
again which is very interesting because
again mark is the one who has the body
he is the original person unless somehow
they managed to change all that in the
mcu here we also learned something that
is very important the reason mark wants
to divorce leila and stay away from her
is because konchu wants her as his next
avatar when mark is done when he's
repaid his debt he's going to choose her
and he doesn't want that to happen so
that's why he's distancing himself from
her and here we see mark and steven go
at it steven doesn't believe anything
that mark says and mark just wants
steven to shut up and eventually mark
destroys the mirror of which steven's
reflection is in and he goes away but as
steven goes away konchu appears now
kanji confirms more of the origin he
says that when i found you you were
nothing but a corpse and your body
actually belongs to me because i brought
you back to life now konchu says that
he'll protect mark with everything he
has because he's worth protecting
although we're not sure how genuine
konchu actually is because he's trying
to go back on the deal that him and mark
made telling them that they need each
other and he says that you're probably
not gonna like my next candidate if we
should part because we know it's gonna
be layla then the final scene ends with
mark in egypt and we see stephen looking
through the reflection in a mirror
looking pretty miserable but steven is
in egypt now and he's going to try to
get to amit's tomb before arthur does so
they can stop him and that is episode 2.
again be sure to let me know all your
thoughts and theories about episode 2 in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on all the latest marvel
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
[Music]